[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and job
or is that pretty thick of a Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast with two
brothers answer you question could be do
be surprised and print you although
exclusive but bars of AFC Wimbledon John
how are you doing today
well Hank I have just returned from a
four hour trip to Ikea so so not like it
was like a four-hour drive to get there
oh no no it's only about thirty minutes
away but we spent a long time at IKEA we
there was many things that needed to be
purchased oh it was a it was a big
endeavor I have never been to one what I
imagine having heard about them is that
it's basically like you go in and and
then you have to like walk a
predetermined path like there's no like
there's no like aisles like a grocery
store I don't know if this is how IKEA
is but this is how I imagine it yeah no
aisles is just like a maze like a
labyrinth that you have to walk through
and you just and then at the end of the
labyrinth you is the cashier you know
that is astonishingly accurate that is
more or less exactly what IKEA is like
the only difference from your
imagination and reality is that at the
end before you get to the cashiers
there's this huge warehouse where you
have to pick out everything that you
want and none of it is of course made
and so it's all to go home in flat boxes
but and right if the hours of labor with
you and yours very small allen wrench do
they have hot dogs at IKEA I don't know
because the last thing I wanted to do
was spend another hour there eating I
will say this though it is a wonderful
wonderful test of where you're at with
your marriage to make IKEA furniture
together it's just a great way to check
in on am I able to cooperate with this
person in extremely difficult
circumstances I feel the same way about
building furniture and checking in with
yourself like if you can build an item
of furniture without a single time
screaming or throwing something across
the room
you basically are like like six Pat like
six steps down the path to enlightenment
yeah I've never gotten anywhere close to
that I've never finished an Ikea project
without crying and that includes just a
few minutes ago when all I had to do was
screw four screws into the back of a
chair still couldn't do it alright let's
get to some questions from our listeners
so that was a very good poem to start us
out with John it was really touching
okay let's get to some questions from
our listeners this person comes from
Tyler who writes dear John and Hank I
recently came into the possession of a
very significant amount of Lacroix I won
the grand prize of their holiday
giveaway what which is a year's supply
of Lacroix however I don't know how much
of a grasp Lacroix has on how much of
their product even an enthusiast such as
myself consumes in a year as I will be
receiving 100 cases of 24 cans of piece
which of course comes out to 2,400 cans
of Lacroix my question to you is this
what does one do with 2,400 cans of
Lacroix I could of course throw a
Lacroix themed party but what activities
could there be besides enjoying the
delicious natural essence of Lacroix any
dubious advice is appreciated Tyler okay
I okay so I guess this is like a year's
supply of Lacroix for a family of four
maybe no I don't like little Croix but
but and I almost came at Tyler for being
like are you would true enthusiast if
you don't drink and then I did the math
six and a half cans of Lacroix a day
that seems like a lot I think I could
drink six and a half cans Ithaca
actually if what curly wants to send me
2,400 cans of Lacroix I will right now
guarantee you that I will drink all
2,400 cans myself over the course of one
year and then you'll just build an
airplane with the leftover aluminium
well I suppose I suppose there is the
the environment to consider but maybe
maybe I'll just use the aluminium to
build a new addition onto my house to
hold all of my new IKEA furniture so
additional question I didn't realise
that when you got a year's supply of
something you got it
upfront like if you get a year supply of
Snickers like do you do you have like a
like AB area of your house that is now
Snickers toes I'm like I buy like a like
a week or twos worth of food at a time
if I have a year's supply of anything
it's gonna take up more space than all
the rest of the food in my house
especially apparently 2,400 cans of
Lucroy not only that but I mean I'm not
an expert in food safety everyone knows
that but it seems to me that drinking a
year old Lacroix has to be not quite as
good as drinking like a freshly canned
Lacroix I feel deeply that that is not
the case I bet I bet there is not a
significant chemical difference between
those two Lacroix
Tyler you have to have a series of
Lacroix parties you have to have one
every month for the entire year and
you'll become known in your community as
the Lacroix boy and it'll be great it'll
be great for you and then the craziest
thing about it Tyler is that when all
these parties are over and when you're
having the last Lacroix party from your
year's supply of Lacroix you're gonna
find yourself thinking I want this to
continue just like I did at the end of
the Brotherhood 2.0 project I did with
my brother and you're gonna go out and
you're gonna buy your own 24 hundred
cans of Lacroix so that you can continue
to be the Lacroix boy for the rest of
your life and I for one celebrate that
Tyler I hope that you have a Lacroix
party once a month every year every
month for the rest of your life
and it's not that expensive I'm looking
at Boka Lacroix is and you can get 24
fur for just ten bucks
no it's $1,000 a year yeah you know you
could be spending that like you probably
spend more than that on on coffee the
question no probably not
where's you get this coffee it gets his
coffee at the very expense of this
coffee place it's called mmm smoosh me
coffee and it's got all the best and
there's meatballs too
I lost the podcast notes John it also
back quick question can you turn your
Lacroix into profit I don't mean
resell the Lacroix but I mean like maybe
it'd be like three Lacroix at the thing
that you do where you also provide a
service or sell items that is such a
Hank green way to get rid of 2,400 cans
of Lacroix is there any way that you can
skirt the rules in order to accidentally
make money you could you could also just
save money by saying okay everybody I'm
having a potluck once a week for you my
friends free Lacroix and I'll also have
a bag of chips you bring food and that's
good you're getting you won't have to
buy the food as much that's a great idea
do you think you'd get tired of Lacroix
if you drink six and a half cans of it a
day every day for a year because I don't
think I would I assumed that they also
provided a variety of flavors it's not
just just Pomplamoose it's a bunch and
and I think in that case no I would not
I'd be like oh but I would I would
discover that I had a favorite and I
would regret the fact that I had so much
tangerine and I don't really like it
that much I you know I used to not like
tangerine Hank I
I find myself whenever I find a Lacroix
flavor I don't like I get it more often
as a way of trying to train my palate
into understanding why
phlex the geniuses at McRoy chose to
release this flavor like obviously they
know more about sparkling water than I
do they make the greatest sparkling
water in the world so if they say that
tangerine tastes good I need to keep
drinking it until I understand that they
are right and in the case of tangerine
that did actually happen now there have
been a few Lacroix flavors that I just
have not been able to bring myself
around to but I haven't quit I'm very
impressed by your efforts John we have
talked a lot about Lacroix and I have
several other things to say but I'm
gonna move on instead does that seem
like a good plan yeah sure if you don't
want to get a la croix sponsorship but
yeah go ahead and move on this question
is from Sarah who asks dear Hank and
John I've been watching eons on YouTube
recently and I'm absolutely loving it
it's our show at youtube.com slash Aeons
in the episode the search for earlier
life
Blake mentions a quote team of Japanese
scientists found
some rocks and the article of their work
published showed on screen what I'm
wondering is in the mention of the
scientists being Japanese is that
necessary
is there something about their study or
published work that makes it necessary
to inform that the scientists were from
Japan I wonder if this is also similar
in literature world saying like a
Japanese writer is their inherent racism
when mentioning these details
dftba sarah in general when we talk
about scientific publications we usually
will say on scishow anyway we'll say
like a team of scientists from the
University of blank because you want to
give credit to the people from that
University what I suspect is the
situation here the actual situation is
that it was from multiple different
Japanese universities and so we
shortened it to a team of Japanese
scientists yeah that's possible I also
you hear this a lot with artists like
when artists are identified in wall
labels or when they're identified in
episodes of the art assignment or
whatever their nationality is usually
stated and I've heard a few reasons for
that in talking to curators about this
one of the reasons I've heard is that it
helps people to understand that people
are doing work all over the world that
people are making art all over the world
another reason is that it helps people
to understand where there might be more
support for the Arts so one reason you
might say a team of Japanese researchers
is if they were working across multiple
universities in Japan partly with
government funding from the Japanese
government so yeah I'm definitely not an
expert about this but I think it's
pretty common across disciplines and
when it comes to authors I usually
assume that people state nationality as
a way of stating the the language in
which the text was originally written
but I don't know it's always it's always
felt very weird to me when I'm traveling
and people introduced me as an American
author I always feel really
uncomfortable with that because there's
the idea of like the American writer is
it's just a little problematic to me and
for a few reasons but yeah let's move on
but I yeah I do like that you know I
think that it's good to say to introduce
that there is other work going on in
other places in the world because if you
just say a team of researchers our
brains sort of default to the default
and our brain is if you're an American
you're your brain will default to it
being American and that might even be
the case for a lot of places a lot of
people might assume a team of
researchers means a team of American
researchers just because there's an
awful lot of research that gets done in
America and it's good to spread that
love and let people know that
interesting things are happening all
over the world all right Hank we've got
a great great question from Patrick
usually I don't enjoy it when people
email dear Hank and John and ask us to
do their homework for them but in this
particular case I did enjoy it because I
like to the homework assignment Patrick
writes Dear John and Hank in English
class we are learning about fake news
and propaganda and as an assessment we
have to write a fake news story among
other things the only problem is I have
no idea what to write it on can you give
me some ideas Patrick he had also at a
very long Latin sign-off but I'm not
even gonna try to read it because it
doesn't lend itself to my talents but
the good news here Patrick is that I am
an expert in fake news I have retweeted
so much of it I mean in the science
world it's so easy to create fake news
and people do it all the time you all
you have to do is say that something
that's bad for you is actually good for
you right people take that up like it's
like Oh chuckles good now excellent
we're gonna write a lot of stories about
that
that's excellent headline here's the
thing Tyler a good fake news story does
exactly one thing it confirms a belief
that someone already has with a fake
fact so if you are trying to convince me
to retweet fake news tell me that
somebody wearing a make America great
again hat did something terrible yes yes
you're trying to get somebody who
disagrees with me to retweet fake news
tell them that you know the somebody who
committed a heinous crime did
so because they were such huge fans of
Hillary Clinton or if you want to get
John to retweet some fake news you got
it you got to talk about like write a
story in which all of the players of AFC
Wimbledon did something really great to
support gun control it's just all of his
favorite things all at one well okay
that's that's actually a good example
though Hank because one of the keys to
fake news is it has to be in an area
where the person who's reading it and
sharing it doesn't actually know that
much about it because if it were that if
it were that AFC Wimbledon's story I
would immediately be suspicious right
because like I know a lot about AFC
Wimbledon there are no AFC wimbledon
press releases
I don't read there are no like AFC
Wimbledon news stories with which I am
unfamiliar so like you you don't you
don't play to someone's expertise you
play to their biases that's true if
that's true you got a cut you got to
come in from an area of ignorance and in
general it's just about helping people
in in a kind of way helping people feel
more comfortable in their perspective on
the world and and and that is that is
the nicest way to say it
yeah fake news tells you you were right
all along even when the data said you
were wrong you were right well that's
why you've been eating so much chocolate
for your whole life also Patrick I would
like to apologize for having just
repeatedly called you Tyler Tyler was
the liquor oh boy
sorry it's a fake news podcast today I'm
only calling people by wrong names this
lacroix boy spelled with an o IX John of
course I hadn't realized that that's
exciting this next question comes from
mrs. Robinson who asks dear Hank and
John how does one finance baby my
husband and I really want a third member
of our family to love and cuddle but we
have no idea how to pay for all the
things it will need
I can't imagine both of us working
full-time with a baby in the house and
it doesn't and doesn't it kind of defeat
the purpose of having a baby if you hire
someone else to do all the day-to-day
loving
and changing a poopy diapers well we
have to come up with a budget yes
I can't imagine our current strategy of
just don't spend money will be
applicable to having a needy baby
depending on us I haven't read any of
the baby books do any of them cover
budgets how did you guys and your
families decide you could afford this
timeless very tiring very expensive
adventure your dubious advice as much
appreciated god bless you please mrs.
Robinson great names Pacific sign off
really good babies are expensive and
forever like they don't stop being
expensive unless and until they get a
job and and also probably even a time
after that yeah I would say five years
after baby gets its first job is maybe
when you can begin to think that the
money that you make is yours again I
don't so there are books about this but
I did find that there were they were
separate they were separate kinds of
books there was the baby books about
babies and then there was the parenting
books about parenting and money which
like are not and I kind of wish I liked
and I when I had like my childbirth
classes the conversations about money
were very infrequent and and
uncomfortable with all the people in the
room and of course people are in
different situations and so that is kind
of bound to happen to some extent but
but it is extremely important to be
thinking about it now and and also to be
thinking that like yes your current
strategy of just not spending money will
not be applicable anymore though there
are lots of ways to save money and to
not spend money and to avoid falling
into the oh this thing is so cute I need
to buy it or you know do you know just
just having the things that people give
you are fine having a baby shower people
are gonna give you a bunch of stuff that
will get you set off on the right foot
but but yes when your family gets more
complicated you should be thinking about
money in a more serious way yeah I do
think that budgeting is key I also want
to say for the record I remember when we
were
going through this because this is in
2009 I think Hank by the time you made
the decision to have a baby you and
Katherine were in a pretty secure
financially yes not not couldn't you
yeah but when Sarah and I were thinking
about having Henry in 2009 we did feel
like oh maybe we should wait a few years
until you know hopefully things are a
little steadier financially and we got
some advice from people who said you're
never gonna feel ready and I think
that's true
but I think you need to feel ready
enough like you aren't you aren't ever
gonna be ready to have a child because
it's such an all at once change it's one
of the very few proper like event
changes in a human life it's really
intense and it actually does happen all
at once unlike most things that are sort
of processes that we we try to ritualize
with events I found it very helpful to
have a budget but it was still stressful
and and and we were in the scheme of
things extremely lucky and so but it was
still very stressful my my main advice
to you is to lean into the baby shower
if you can because most the expensive
stuff is upfront costs except for
diapers which are unbelievably expensive
and also just want to say that I don't
buy the argument that there's no point
in having a baby if you have to have
childcare yeah I agree
there's no diapers yeah there's plenty
there are plenty of poopy diapers there
are plenty of opportunities to love and
to hug on your child even if you have to
work and Sarah and I both worked when we
went back to work when Henry was 12
weeks old and I don't think that Henry
feels any sense of loss from that in
fact I think it was good for him in some
ways to be exposed to different kinds of
people and to be to feel loved and
supported by a variety of people instead
of just two so obviously every family is
different there's I don't think there's
one right way to parent but I don't
think that you should feel like it's
inherently a tragedy if if a kid has it
goes to daycare yeah of course not and
and also I'd like absolutely feel
comfortable relying on friends and
family if you have those those
opportunities
both for childcare but also for just
financial support if you need that and
you know like you're like to some extent
if grandparents are around to help they
might very well it like that yeah they
might not I mean it depends on the
grandparent you got and parent you got
to live with the family you get but
we've been very we've been very lucky I
have to say with lots and lots of our
kids get lots and lots of love from lots
of places and that's been a real
blessing for us this next question comes
from April who writes dear John and Hank
almost every time I get in my car I
worried that I'll be pulled over for
speeding April I know exactly what this
is like I've I spend so much time
worrying about being pulled over for
speeding I don't speed that much and
have never been pulled over for speeding
but I've seen it in the movies and I
know that the police officer asks do you
know how fast you were going and what
frightens me is not the speeding ticket
but how in the world am I going to
answer that question if I say yes does
it make it better because I knew I was
speeding and take accountability or is
it better to say no and feign ignorance
please help me so I can be prepared if
this day ever comes not February pralaya
have gotten the question instead of Dina
how fast you were going
it's do you know why I pulled you over I
could be so many different things yeah I
don't
are you a singing telegram is it a good
thing my there's like I always have this
impulse to confess every crime I've ever
committed when confronted with the
police officer for him to be like hey do
you know why I pulled you over and me to
be like is it because is it because I
smoked cigarettes when I was 16 I did I
bought them I bought them at kusa
liquors were they catered because I
kissed Cheryl when I was still kind of
going steady with Miranda like if that
why no that's what we were super
separated I they promise okay when you
get that question you answer it by
saying
I don't know why you pulled me over that
is the correct answer I do not know why
you pulled me over a police officer once
asked me is there any reason why you're
not wearing your seatbelt and I was
wearing my seatbelt it was just that my
shirt was the same color as the seatbelt
and I was like I don't know
this thing that I'm wearing help my
assumption has always been that they ask
you do you know why I'm pulling you over
on the off chance that you might say is
it because of the eight hundred pounds
of heroin in my trunk
is it because I'm the murderer murdered
so many people and I've just been
waiting to be caught or you just say are
you just like sigh and say yes and then
get out of the car and put your hands
behind your back no I April
I have not gotten a speeding ticket this
is a point of tremendous pride for me I
have not gotten a speeding ticket since
I was 22 years old however when I got
that speeding ticket when I was 22 I the
moment I began to roll down the window
first off I was in tears secondly I
immediately said to the police officer I
am so sorry this is entirely my fault I
did not know what the speed limit was
and I am sorry and I thought you know
maybe that'll get me a war it didn't it
got me a $242 speeding ticket you know
that that's my recommendation April just
listen make no sudden movements and and
everything is gonna probably be okay but
I can't completely I share this worry so
I feel like I can't completely calm you
down yeah my my last time I got a
speeding ticket was September 22nd mm
what was it seven I think okay and I
know that because of the day before I
got married oh man you were in a right
state it was 2006 2006 by the way it was
2005 recently I recently got into a car
accident Hank my first car accident Oh
No yeah almost 15 years and it is so
true that when you're in
in an emotionally overwhelmed place you
become a much worse driver I ran into a
postal service vehicle which was
tremendously embarrassing but also
annoying because even though the damage
was quite minor of course that car is
owned by the United States federal
government and so there were layers
involved in getting you know to the
point where I could drive away and it
would never have happened except that my
poor dog is dying and it's been it's
been a very stressful couple of months
and then also there a bunch of
professional stresses going on at the
same time and I the moment I backed into
this postal vehicle I was just like oh
this never would have happened if I'd
been not stressed out and that is
exactly what it was like before your
wedding
you were you were in a state I was in a
state I was a even know that that's like
the place where the cops pull people
over
you should always it's like the
speedometer goes from like 35 to 25 for
this like four block stretch and it the
damn road doesn't change at all it's cuz
it's by the hospital and yeah I I did I
did the thing John but it's uh yeah
it turned out okay thank you for being
with me during that during that
stressful time I don't know why it's
like the most freaked out I've been in
my whole life
like happy about it like right it's not
it's not it's not about whether you're
happy about it it's just a really
intense thing and I remember my wedding
as mostly being very very intense I
often say that like the first 12 hours
of my marriage were the most difficult
12 hours so far my wedding really really
stressed me out so I I can relate yeah I
mean once it happened I was super super
down it was the it was the 24 48 hours
beforehand that was not just events man
they're hard it's hard to run an event
then I did it for a living
for like you're like I'm so good at this
I think I should make it my job this
next questions comes from Katya who asks
dear Hank and John I just listened to
your podcast episode in which you give
advice on how to befriend a crow it just
so happens that I have the opposite of
that problem for some reason my room
decided to become friends with the many
crows that live in our neighborhood
every time she goes out no boy oh boy
every time she goes out she feeds them
some walnuts in the hope that they will
recognize her face and see her as an
ally
I guess not oh god that'll come in handy
when the apocalypse rolls around and you
got a bunch of bird friends I told her
from the start that I thought this was a
bad idea a crows creeped me out
why wouldn't you want to befriend them
well a few weeks ago I woke up and got a
heart attack when I saw four crows
perched in a row on the balcony railing
they were watching me sleep
I think the curette they won't go away
how do i unfriend the murder oh god I
forgot that a group of crow what's a
group of crows called Henry do you
remember a murder a murder of crows
Henry's here by the way Henry do you
want to say hi to the podcast hi n ray
hey Henry do you think it's a good idea
or a bad idea to become friends with
crows a good idea why I could fly on
their backs
you mean like a group of crows could
like hold me up and take me places I
guess but they're crows I mean couldn't
I do the same thing with like golden
eagles
wouldn't that be cooler all right it
would hurt more because of their beaks
why the talons I guess that's true
Henry's thought this through he thinks
that you should befriend crows so that
you can fly Isis well maybe that's what
your roommate is thinking of Katya I
don't you like the thing is the
difference between unfriending a crow
and making a crow enemy seems a very
fraught I agree that's a very fine line
and as much as you don't want to be
friends with these crows who are
watching you sleep
the thing you really don't want kaca is
to have a bunch of enemies have crow
enemies that sounds very scary
this is because they act this is the
exact same problem I have with Facebook
it's like I maybe I don't like I'm just
you know he said you could just get a
bat and hit them yeah no you can't do
that Henry it's a solution but I think
it's a crime
yeah it's also they're very fast crows
this is the I feel like the exact
problem that I have with Facebook which
is I can't like I feel like not being
friends with someone on Facebook once
you are friends with them is like a very
active decision and right I do not want
I just want to be like I just don't like
you're just not part of my life anymore
but I don't want to say like unfriended
like I'm like I'm hitting them off of my
facebook stream with a bat and just be
like you're out you know and I have and
and so and thus the crow situation also
must be dealt with similarly which is
just ghost them yeah caught you you're
gonna have to ghost not just the crows
but definitely your roommate I would
argue that the underlying issue here is
the roommate and like I'm not telling
you to be terrified of your roommate and
her crow by friending activities but I
mean do move are the crows on Facebook
can you unfriend them that way oh that's
a good idea try to mate try to be as
passive-aggressive about it as possible
crows crows I'm not I'm just not doing
this anymore I'm moving to Vero Bureau
is this new social network and it's
totally cool cuz it's not like Facebook
cuz it's different from Facebook in ways
and so if you're not gonna move over to
fear oh we just can't be friends and the
most important way it's different from
Facebook is that crows aren't allowed to
join yeah and crows can't join veer oh I
know that that's weird but it's just
like for now until the the network gets
bigger they can't they can't have crows
on so much of my life I didn't have a
facebook and I think on average I don't
know I don't want to talk about it let's
move on to a different question
this podcast is brought to you by vero
that new social network that everyone's
talking about that is different from
Facebook somehow today's podcast lesson
brought to you by singing policemen
telegrams singing policemen telegrams
the best reason for getting pretty you
know how fast you're going
it's 37 your birthday guess also brought
to you by Tyler the Lacroix boy
Tyler the Lacroix boy go to his potluck
there's free Lacroix and lastly today's
podcast is brought to you by IKEA
furniture IKEA furniture testing the
well-being of marriages and individuals
since 1971 and also we have a project
for awesome message from Jackie in
Colorado this message is for Maggie as
donation to the project for awesome
thank you very much for that Jackie it
says happy 25th birthday mags as it
turns out sending 25 puppies to you in
Scotland it's a little bit impractical
but I figured a podcast announcement
would be an entertaining alternative
gift plus it's for charity
have a fantastic day celebrating and
take a well-deserved study break the
green brothers set it so you have to
follow through tah-tah ladi Dadi day
don't forget to be awesome
ain't completely messed that up but I'm
gonna crush it are you ready Maggie here
it is right Tata la de da de and don't
forget to be awesome
what is that a thing that I should know
about no I just I just read it correctly
and you read on top top of la vie de da
de navidad a Tata Tata Tata Tata Tata
Tata ta Tata la-dee-da it's like I don't
know I feel like that's try to be from
something right now it's like when I
it's probably probably is from Avatar
The Last Airbender and we're about to
get 250,000 correction notes whenever I
try to say something in Spanish Henry
just looks at me blankly for the longest
time and then eventually he'll say it
back to me but correctly and then I'll
try to say it correctly and he'll just
he it's the first time I've seen him
roll his eyes he's begun to just roll
his eyes and say no dad you can't do it
so stop trying it's an embarrassment
this next question comes from Amy who
writes dear John and Hank often your
life advice saying things along the
lines of follow your passion and dreams
but is it wrong to want a nine-to-five
job and have your passions be side gigs
why do so many songs have lines bragging
about not having a nine-to-five job I'm
about to finish an undergrad in music
and while I love playing instruments I'm
extremely exhausted from the lack of a
daily routine in my class and rehearsal
schedules and from what I can tell from
talking to my teachers that's what a
career in music is am i a quitter or
letting down myself or my teachers if I
get a nice nine-to-five job in the best
place on earth a library and be a
part-time musician not wanting to
disappoint Amy
man Amy it seems like you've got your
stuff together yeah you know exactly
what you want Amy you're crushing it
don't let anybody tell you that you're
not crushing it you know what you what
you want to do for a job you want to
work in a library which is awesome and
you know what you want to do as a side
gig which is awesome as well I think
this is great and it's also really
wonderful if you understand about
yourself that you're someone who
benefits from routine and structure and
that's where you thrive like I that took
me a long time to understand about
myself and when I stopped having a job I
had always had day jobs and sort of
wrote at night and on the weekends and I
was very comfortable with that but then
when we had enough money for me to stop
doing that and I was able to write
full-time I was like oh this is great
I'm gonna be living the dream that's the
dream to write all day and within like
two weeks of living the dream I was like
this is terrible like I understand that
this is the dream but it turns out it's
not my dream like my dream involves a
certain amount of routine and seeing
other adults during the day and lots of
other things that weren't possible for
me when I was ostensibly writing
full-time and so slowly I built more and
more day jobs so that I could come to an
office work 9:00 to 5:00 and write at
night and on the weekends because that's
where I'm productive and happy yeah I've
been thinking a lot about the ways that
we
in success and how insidious that can be
when when we create definitions of
success that require things almost like
it's almost sort of a requirement that
any definition of success that really
resonates with us is something that only
a few people can have and yeah otherwise
if everybody can have it that can't be
that great right and that is such a
destructive terrible thing not just for
individuals but for society as a whole
because we need that like have a society
where the most people possible can be
experiencing their lives as a worthwhile
exciting success and I like it's really
and like I've become very sort of like
apprehensive about the the things that I
do for a living and people seeing that
as a goal that they want to have because
this is definitionally like my job is
definitionally something that can only
be had by not very many people because
you need a large audience in order to
support like a youtube show or a podcast
and so not everybody can have a large
audience because there's a unless marked
time of the day gets manufactured so I
worry about that and and having gone
through and watched the first season of
the new queer eye on Netflix I you know
seeing those people sort of moving to a
place where they are more happy with an
accepting of their life as it exists is
is really exciting though I worry that
like in the examples given in that show
like it requires a bunch of money to be
spent on your clothes and your hair and
your house and I like it worries me and
like I love the show don't get me wrong
like I'm a super fan of this and I wish
there were more episodes I can't but I
like got really sad when I found out
that it was over but I just want there
to be ways for us to feel like a
successful people without having to have
that be based on other people and like
and and sort of like maybe somewhat
unrealistic expectations for what a life
can be yeah I mean the other thing about
that Hank and you know I obviously come
to this question from an extraordinary
privileged and specific perspective but
my experience has been both in having a
measure of public renown and in knowing
lots of people with with much more
public renown
it is tremendously overrated like it is
overrated on on a scale that baffles me
because the truth is and it's a hard
truth to talk about I think but the
truth is that it for lots and for most
people I think it's very disorienting
it's very scary it's not particularly
fun and there's a feeling at least I
felt this after the success of The Fault
in Our Stars and again I want to
acknowledge how grateful I am for that
success and how wonderful it was but I
also think that to be fair I should
acknowledge that like I was not having a
good time like I was not I was deeply
deeply unhappy and I was sick and I was
scared all the time and I was completely
overwhelmed and I realized that it was
another time when I realized that like
just because something is the dream just
because something is is the thing that
you're told to try to accomplish by the
social order doesn't mean it's
necessarily the thing you actually want
to accomplish but it's so so hard to
disentangle your interests and your
passions and who you are from what the
social order wants you to be or what the
social order of values and so one of the
things I loved about this question is
that you know this is someone who seems
to have a pretty good handle on who she
is and what she wants and I think Amy
you should celebrate that I think you
should be excited about that and I think
you should pursue the life that you want
to have especially because you're lucky
to understand what that is agree I think
is the thing that we all would do well
to think more about that stuff not just
for our own sakes but for everybody's
because we're maybe headed into a world
where it gets harder and harder to lead
the kind of life that people can imagine
as a success and that doesn't that leads
to a much less happy Society which has
a lot of negative impacts I got another
question John it's from Anna and it's
about sand dear Hank and John how much
sand is there this is a great question I
know the answer you know the answer to
how much sand there is yeah I hope and
is there who asked the question again is
her name Anna yeah
and I'm about to blow your mind okay you
probably already know this Anna but I
still think it's amazing there are more
stars in the universe then there are
grains of sand on earth or something
like that
no there it's not even close okay I
believe you
that's it I am i i i believe i that's
there's a carl sagan quote that's there
more stars i think in the galaxy than
there are grains of sand on every Beach
in the world the thing that to be really
specific about though John is we don't
know how many grains of sand there are
in the universe and that's what Anna
asked about oh how much sand is there oh
yeah like in the universe there's a lot
of sand Anna it's I mean there's a ton
like well actually weigh more than a ton
there's a lot of sand in the universe
there's a lot the question of whether my
guess is that there is more sand in the
universe than there are stars in the
universe but I don't know that for
certain
well that's my yes cuz I bet there's a
lot of a lot of good rocky planets with
water running around making yeah it's
very very cieariy be like mostly sand
there's a lot of sand on Mars
yeah our dust I guess whatever the
difference is between those things so
yeah I think they're probably a lot of
there's a lot of sand you want to know
something else weird that I learned from
the same thing where I learned this
about the sand yeah if you took ten
drops of water regular drops of water
and you counted the number of molecules
of h2o in those 10 drops of water mm-hmm
you would get a number approximately
equal to all the stars in the universe
okay and so John well I told you there
is more there
more stars in the universe than there
are grains of sand on earth so how about
so this is the answer to okay if you
assume if grain of sand has an average
size and you calculate how many grains
are in a teaspoon and then multiply by
all the beaches and deserts in the world
the earth has roughly and we're speaking
very roughly here 7.5 times 10 to the
18th grains of sand or seven quintillion
five hundred quadrillion grains of sand
whereas the the universe has just an
absolute crap ton of stars the number is
non specific but it's more than ten to
the 18 it's bigger than that which I
believe no I know I'm pretty sure that
isn't that the current wait hold on
isn't that the current thought about how
many stars there are in the universe an
absolute crap Tom yeah oh yeah
nope--like nada not a relative crap ton
but an absolute absolute crap ton Anna's
question actually goes on to say since
sand is made from rocks getting crumbled
up into pieces there's more and more
sand being made all the time right if
that balanced out by the creation of new
sedimentary rock is the amount of saw is
the amount of sand increasing or
decreasing if it's increasing does that
mean that there's infinite sand bun Anna
banana banana hmm that's a great name
specifics I know so it's important to
understand something here Anna which is
that even if the amount of grains of
sand is increasing there's a finite
amount of matter on earth so the number
of grains of sand will never be infinite
correct that's good because it means
even in the universe there might be
infinite sand in the universe
unfortunately possibly just to confuse
matters further that's true it could
it's possible but it's hard to know for
sure there are 7 times 10 to the 22nd
stars in the known universe anymore
that's way more than we got sands
to this website and this oh that is
actually the scientific definition of an
absolute crap-ton is 7 times 10 to the
22nd yeah like
the systems that plate techtonics that
is currently sort of that is converting
the geological processes generally that
it's converting sand into sedimentary
rock is going on and will continue going
on whether or not those things are in
balance at the moment I don't know I
don't know if there's like more sand
being made by crumbling than there is
sedimentary rock being made but you are
quite correct and intelligent to
identify the fact that sand eventually
becomes rock again which is pretty cool
all right Hank so we know that there is
a finite amount of sand on earth and
that that situation will continue yeah
do you want to give me the noose term
AFC Wimbledon John I mean part of me
does part of me doesn't okay here's the
news from AFC Wimbledon Hank we played
Peterborough in in the League One the
third tier of English football it was a
good game while Taylor scored a
fantastic goal and it looked like AFC
Wimbledon were going to get three points
which would have been very very useful
but then Peterborough scored an
equaliser which is extremely frustrating
and disheartening and so it was a 1-1
draw AFC Wimbledon got one point which
moved them from 37 points to 38 points
they remain in 18th place but they are
only two points away right now from a
relegation spot the 36 points is what
the team in 21st F 21st 22nd 23rd and
24th will all spend next season in the
fourth tier of English football
so Wimbledon are two points clear of the
drop zone right now with 12 games to
play from those 12 games we need about
14 points to guarantee our place in
league or close to guarantee our place
and leave one next season Hank how many
points per game is that I don't know
you're thinking about it I'm gonna go on
and give you an update but in all
likelihood we actually need 14 points
from 11 games because our next game is
against Blackburn and they are at the
top of Ligue 1 and are just amazing this
year I mean as third tier English
football teams go and we'll there
likely beat AFC Wimbledon I think even
yeah so then we need 14 points from 11
games basically we still need to win
five games but now we only have 11 games
in which to do it so I am officially
very nervous well you need one point two
seven points per game to get a lot of
points and those yeah to get the
fourteen points out of the eleven games
that's it's it's nerve-racking so gosh
that is scary it's it's I it's there's
nothing obviously that I can do about it
from the United States but it is Oh God
it's it's a worry I just I just really
hope the dawns find a way to stay up I
think that they've got some great young
talent
I think things could look really good
next year and then hopefully the year
after that we'll be in the new stadium
that will be a huge huge deal for the
future and the security of the club so
ah yeah if we could stay in Ligue 1 for
another two seasons it would be great
but obviously it's going to be tough
this year I will say Simon bassy who's
been with the club since they were
formed he participated in the tryouts on
Wimbledon Common back in 2002 and was
part of the team for a few years before
joining the coaching staff
Simon bassy had a great series of kind
of come-to-jesus moments with the fans
where he was like look we used to have
the smallest Stadium in Ligue 2 now we
have the smallest Stadium and leave one
the odds have always been stacked
against us and I know that it's really
frustrating to watch your team go out
and struggle week after week but we need
to be in this together you know the
great thing about having a fan owned
Club is that we really are in it
together all of us who are members of
the Dons trust own the club just as much
as Simon bassy or any other fan does and
so that was really heartening and
inspiring to me the way he talked about
all of us being in this together and how
the team was gonna need the fans just as
the fans were gonna need the team so I
am worried but I am also feeling that
resolve that he is instilled in me great
great and it's not and and you'll go
back and have
the biggest stadium and the fourth or
the smallest eighth in the fourth tier
until that stadium gets finished and you
know they'll still be impressive that
you're that you've come so far I'd
really rather not suffer Wimbledon's
first relegation since being reformed in
2002 but obviously yeah the universe
that time is is infinite John it will
have to happen eventually
mhm not that is not true oh that is not
true that is very possible that the
world will end before Wimbledon ever get
relegated and and may that be the case
let me know yes yes what's the news from
Mars and news from Mars the trace gas
orbiter which is part of the ExoMars
exploration program which is two
missions one of which crashed into Mars
but this one did not the European led
mission has just finished its very long
term
aerobraking maneuver to get into the
orbit that it needs to be in - to do its
science so when you go to Mars you you
are going very fast because you have to
get there you have to get out of the
Earth's gravity you have to be
accelerating out of you know away from
the Sun to get further away from the Sun
and then you get there you're going very
fast you have to slow down there's two
ways to do that really one is you have
rockets that have fuel and you use those
Rockets to slow down and go into orbit
around or around the planet and that
then you have to carry all that fuel
with you which is bad but sometimes
missions will just crash into the
atmosphere going is like just crazy fast
burn off some blade of plates and have
parachutes to slow down and Rockets to
slow down and they use mostly but though
the youth the atmosphere to slow down
but when you're in orbiter you can't
just crash into the planet and slam into
the atmosphere like that so instead you
like they have this very long period of
time
where I think over 900 times the orbiter
went around the planet and on one of the
orbits it skims the back or out on one
side of the
orbit it skims the planet's atmosphere
and then it goes way out in this long
looping orbit and then it comes again it
skims the atmosphere again and each time
it slows down a little bit because it
crashes into the the atoms on the very
very top layer of the Mahr of the very
thin Martian atmosphere and that's what
EXO Mars has been doing for over a year
it's been it's been slamming into the
end of those atoms slowing down and now
it is in its final final orbit and that
means it can start soon
doing its actual science mission which
will be mostly figuring out this mystery
that we've got on Mars right now or at
least part of this mystery which is
methane we have detected methane on the
surface of Mars several times there's
debate about whether that methane was
actually on Mars or whether it was
somehow trapped on the lander that
landed on Mars we've seen methane
several times but we need a more
sensitive instrument and this trace gas
orbiter is going to be it has those
instruments they'll be able to tell how
much methane there is in the Martian
atmosphere or where that methane maybe
is coming from and that's very important
not just because it's interesting but
because methane on earth is mostly
produced by life and if there is some
tiny trace amount of weird life on Mars
it might be producing methane it might
also be consuming methane and and so
understanding the methane cycle on Mars
could be a really important part of
understanding what weird trace life
might actually be happening on the
surface of that planet or beneath the
surface wow that's pretty cool you know
what else is news from Mars this week
what noted Mars fanatic Elon Musk
revealed that his global broadband
StarLink network this constellation that
he is building to try to bring global
broadband to people especially people
who are currently left behind by so much
of the technological revolution that the
name for it was inspired by The Fault in
Our Stars my book or more likely the
movie
here I think yeah I mean who knows
so apparently Ilan John Green fan what
disease of fans Liam must have any
feelings about this [ __ ] no Leone must
has gone quiet recently I'm not sure
what's going on with him I know you said
that that was only gonna be like a thing
that lasted for a few weeks and but I'm
committed to making sure it lasts for
the entire 12 years of the stupid Mars
bet however right now I'm like I don't
enjoy Twitter enough at the moment to be
completely honest with you to have a
novelty account on Twitter I just barely
enjoy it enough to tweet my new vlog
brothers video every week but but yeah I
was really excited about that I thought
that was pretty cool so thank you Elon
Musk for including me making me a
footnote in the incredible story of
global broadband Mars Falcon Heavy
Rockets etc and Thank You Hank for being
the reason that I care enough about this
stuff to follow Elon Musk on Twitter in
the first place
alright John what did we learn today
well we learned that IKEA furniture is
just waiting at my house to be made oh
yeah can't you get I can't ask rabbit to
come help you out with that cinch no I'm
gonna do it by myself
well with Sarah and we learned that 7
times 10 to the 22 is the technical
definition of an absolute crap talk
about we learned that working 9 to 5 is
just fine if you like working 9 to 5 and
finally we learned that there is no such
thing as too much lacroix or at least
I'd like to find out if there's such a
thing as too much work right all right
John thank you for podcasting with me
it's been a joy and thank everybody for
listening and if you leave the ratings
on iTunes that's really great too or
whatever a podcast machine you used to
get podcasts into your podcast
this podcast is edited by Nicholas
Jenkins it's produced by rosianna halse
rojas and Sheridan Gibson our head of
community and communications is Victoria
bon giorno the music you're hearing now
and at the beginning of the podcast is
by the great gunnarolla and as they say
in our hometown don't forget to be
awesome
[Music]